depuis 18 mois environ on voit en france
des hommes et des dames aussi bien
qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les bruits de la circulation
ce sont des walkman vous pouvez apporter
votre prochaine c'est de nous emporter
votre baladeur gaza depuis cinq ans tous
sont de plus en plus nombreux dans le
bus le métro la rue ce casque aux
oreilles et qu'à cet âge ils vivent dans
leur maison pour les connaisseurs le
lecteur de cassettes stéréophonie est
devenu l'indispensable signe
d'appartenance à une certaine caste
image de marque qu'il véhicule et celle
de l'action de la jeunesse et du
dynamisme
ils ont la sensation de pouvoir se
dégager tout ce qui est autour de soi
pouvoir écouter la musique
s'extérioriser lensois même être bien
moi j'utilise une invention qui enchante
surtout les vendeurs 1 millions
d'appareils vendus en france depuis un
onni sont pris entre 800 et 1200 francs
pour une mode
oui mais une mode peut être pas sans
conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la
présence des autres
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant